[Musik]
über die un-klimakonferenz spreche ich
jetzt mit der frau des of user
sprecherin lienen niedecken die ich hat
sich in brüssel begrüßt ronny decken die
kopf 26 ist vorbei hier eine kleine
zusammenfassung
blablabla das twitterte die
klimaaktivisten in kreta team berg was
wäre denn drin gewesen außer blabla
ja was wir eben ganz klar auch in
glasgow gesehen haben ist es vor ort
endlich hunderte tausende aktivisten vor
ort man die schon an den fronten der
klimakrise kämpfen und diese menschen
müssten eben hauptsächlich an den
entscheidung zwischen sitzen um darüber
zu entscheiden das wirklich auch 1,5
grad jetzt sofort eingeleitet wird und
nicht nur als zahl festgeschrieben werde
aber anhand der maßnahmen einfach
physikalisch bisher immer noch
unerreichbar und was wären das für
konkretere maßnahmen die sie fordern
würden wenn diese klima aktivistinnen
mit am tisch saßen
neben sofortige emissionsreduktion das
ist das wichtigste dass wir jetzt sofort
anfangen wirklich drastisch runter zu
fahren denn ihr später mehr anfangen
desto schwieriger wird eben das heißt
ganz klare zugeständnisse also ganz
klare zusagen jetzt bald die
kohleverstromung grund hat zu fahren und
vor allem eben aber auch die
finanzierung so hoch zu fahren das ist
hierfür nicht industrie denn da also
nicht entwickelte länder die
hauptverursacher staaten wie deutschland
eben auch möglich wird überhaupt diese
maßnahmen einzuleiten um 100 prozent
erneuerbar aufzubauen und das ist zum
beispiel über eine front erst jetzt
schuld auch daran dass es jetzt zu
abgeschwächt wurde das auf indien und
china zu schieben ist ganz schön
schwierig wenn die hauptverursacher
starten wie eben eu und usa die seit
jahrzehnten und jahrhunderten
industrialisierung eben profitiert haben
eigentlich dafür sorgen dass den ländern
eben nicht möglich jetzt sitzen bei
solchen konferenzen
197 länder zusammen die alle legitimen
nationale interessen haben und am ende
muss man irgendwie einen kompromiss
finden jetzt haben wir darüber
gesprochen was ihnen fehlt was nicht gut
war was war denn gut welche ergebnisse
sagen sie sind richtig und sind ein weg
ein schritt in die richtige richtung
ich habe schritt in die richtige
richtung war
dem standen mit der klimagerechtigkeit
bewegung aus der ganzen welt angeführt
von indigenen gruppen und eben den am
stärksten betroffenen ländern und dass
wir eben verordnet und interveniert
haben wo eben viel zu wenig passiert ist
und dass diese stimmen eben nicht mehr
überhört werden können bei sonst ist
jetzt nämlich viel zu einfach wäre dazu
sagen okay wir sind doch auf dem
richtigen weg wo er denn wir
gleichzeitig aber immer noch so viel
geld in fossile energien stecken und
absolut mich auch nur ein paar für 15
grad sind und solange wir eben nicht auf
diesen pfad sind und auch wirklich
realistische veränderungen sehen können
wir auch nicht von jetzt einem großen
erfolg sprechen oder so
könnte man es vielleicht als erfolg
werten dass erstmals ja tatsächlich die
kohle oder auch subventionierungen in
fossile energieträger wirklich als
ursache des problems benannt wurden das
ganze auch schriftlich festgehalten
wurde und dass ja die richtung die
marschrichtung klar ist also eine
aufforderung für den ausstieg aus der
kohle glauben sie nicht das ganze hat
doch oder wird über die zeit eine
signalwirkung entfalten nicht nur eine
politische signalwirkung sondern auch in
richtung wirtschaft oder investoren
ich kann verstehen dass man diplomatisch
von einem erfolg sprechen will wenn man
sich aber eben die qualität der
kunstmarkt wieder anschaut dann sind
diese signale sind seit 30 jahren schon
da lebte jetzt schon in einer welt die
eben und katastrophen brennt an allen
ecken und an allen enden und millionen
menschen schon heute darunter leiden ihr
zuhause verlassen müssen und das
passiert also im mittlerweile überall
und da glaube ich jetzt nach 26
klimakonferenzen als großen erfolg zu
den allerersten mal fossile energien auf
benannt werden obwohl wir das seit 30
jahren schon wissen das kann das kann
kein erfolg sein sondern erfolgt müssen
eben emissionsreduktionen sein und so
lagen die emissionen immer noch steigen
also wir sind noch bei steigenden
emissionen wir sind noch nicht mal
runterfahren da müssen eben hinkommen
und ehrlich auch über die klimakrise
reden und nicht nur von signalen ja dann
lassen sie uns über die klimakrise in
deutschland reden auf der kop 26 war
jetzt noch die alte geschäftsführende
bundesregierung vertreten was erwarten
sie ganz konkret von einer neuen
bundesregierung
die neue bundesregierung muss eben ganz
klar voran gehen zum beispiel aufhören
überhaupt noch geld in fossile energien
zu stecken das heißt wir dürfen müssen
fossil ist auf sanktionen so schnell wie
möglich abschaffen und eben soziale den
sozialen wandel dabei immer mitdenken
und das nicht als ausgleich
gegeneinander sondern eben
klimamaßnahmen müssen auch für soziale
maßnahmen und da muss die
bundesregierung eben auch im internet
die internationale verantwortung viel
stärker wahrnehmen das heißt ich sehr
stark dafür einsetzen dass die
internationale klimafinanzierung
deutlich deutlich erhöht wird und eben
die eu zum beispiel eine diese
verantwortungsvolle auch übernimmt und
weniger anderen länder versucht zu
erklären wie es denn funktionieren
sondern vielmehr anfängt zu sagen okay
wir fangen jetzt erst mal an die
zerstörung zu stoppen weil es so lange
ja die noch gestoppt werden haben wir
den ich mit dem hin zu reden wo andere
länder zum beispiel noch kritische
infrastrukturen drin sagte niedecken von
fires of future ich danke für das
gespräch